tonight many months thought would never
happen let's get into some wedding
details I know next summer
kentucky place you always wanted to get
married yes so that's all we've checked
out so far so we have a dress yet I
found a dress yes I did not mean to but
the very first place I went to I
actually found a dress okay I'm not
gonna like announce the designer and
stuff just yet because I don't want him
to like know anything about whenever I
walk down the aisle that's gonna be the
first time that he sees it or knows
anything about what it looks like okay
that's very important to me the cast the
majority will be invited yes who will
not be invited I think it's obvious that
James would not be there I was gonna say
that seems like a safe I think everybody
gonna sing that especially after the
first episode what's the guest number
like how big of a wedding
I think our cap is gonna be around like
200 220 something like that that's like
what we're thinking it was a firm 200 I
will we said Frankie 20 and we weren't
gonna go over to 20 but we gotta like we
got a finalized that way yeah you know
and it is a destination wedding so we're
gonna have some people right yeah I was
gonna say I imagine Lisa's getting an
invite Lisa ever been to Kentucky do you
know I don't know actually um I think I
bet she's been to like maybe the dirt
okay um but I honestly think she's gonna
fit right in that place where we're
getting married is right up her alley so
okay it's it's probably just gonna be a
little jealous she's not actually
staying at the castle it's so beautiful
that she's just gonna be like taken back
because it's exactly her style that I
now pronounce you husband and wife are
you guys pulling a page out of Katie and
Tom's book and having her officiate and
it's very important to my family that I
we have some money from the church okay
yeah and it's important to me to support
amis yeah this is I think I thought what
they did with Lisa was really cool yeah
yeah for them and we love Lisa so it's
not like we would like no we went one
thing well I thought what they do is
really amazing I think it just it works
I'm gonna ask somebody that like
and I went to church with whenever I was
a little girl like hasn't known me my
whole life and he's like a great speaker
just so down are so cool so that's what
I'm hoping for when we go home I'm gonna
ask yeah you got to finalize all these
things you guys are headed to Kentucky
for the holiday yet are we doing all the
finishing touches when were there a lot
of the finishing touches like we're
doing cake tastings and we're doing all
the first gonna figure out our menu yes
we're gonna yeah do do stuff like that
cuz we've kind of figured out like where
we're getting married what we want here
and there and you know we figured all
that stuff out we're doing pretty good
yeah it sounds like you guys are a heavy
knock on wood it's running a lot
separation yes
[Laughter]
[Music]